with the shutdown over air travel delays
are expected to ease as air traffic
controllers go back to work more than
5200 domestic flights were either
canceled or delayed on Friday many of
them due to sick calls by some federal
air traffic controllers Kris Van Cleave
is at Reagan National Airport outside of
Washington Chris good morning good
morning Friday was the day that air
traffic controllers should have gotten
paid they didn't and instead the entire
country got a taste of the strains the
aviation system has been under something
we had been warned about for days making
1744 say you have a roof for you sources
say all it took was six air traffic
controllers calling in sick to cause
major flight delays in New York Friday
morning
those shut down sick calls left
frustrated passengers stuck on some
flights for hours more than 600
LaGuardia flights were delayed I'm
trying to get to a business meeting so
it does cause a lot of anxiety for sure
Maggie Hansen Skyped us from the tarmac
in Des Moines you heard a huge groan
come over the plane the FAA said a
slight increase of sick calls at a
control center outside DC and another in
Jacksonville forced the agency to slow
air traffic which caused a ripple effect
at several major airports in the
Northeast and Florida Paul Rinaldi is
the president of the air traffic
controllers Union I wanted for the
record we do not condone it we did not
organize it they're tired they're
distracted and I think they weren't fit
for duty so they didn't come to work
controllers like Toby huic in Chicago
missed a second paycheck Friday he
welcomed word the shutdown was over but
worries about a three-week solution
something has to be long-term where
we're not in the middle of this fight
that says federal employees should which
not our livelihood should not be messed
with as we move forward
there was another first during the
shutdown was overshadowed in all of this
that happened yesterday an American
Airlines flight from Monroe Louisiana to
Dallas was cancelled because there
weren't enough TSA officers to screen
the 26 passengers we can tell you today
the mood at the checkpoints here at
Reagan is much better Dana yeah Chris
it's always been nice though seeing over
the last three weeks people thanking
those TSA workers while they've been
working without pay
thanks for the very latest